thanks for tuning in everybody welcome
to the show
just want to say one thing at the outset
I made the self-destructive decision
that I often make honestly to read the
comments under the video I did a couple
days ago and somebody said that I look
like that I look like a generic burglar
from an ADT commercial and I just
thought this it's kind of true I don't
know how that's true or what I don't
really but yeah I think it kind of
nailed it so I only bring that up just
just to say that I the problem with all
the insulting that goes on on the
internet and in the comment sections of
the videos I do and the articles I write
is that the insults there's no
imagination no creativity and so it's
very rare that I read one and I say wow
well you know well done well done on
that insult
so all I'm saying to the trolls is just
step your game up a little bit that's
all now I wrote something yesterday on
this subject and I want to expand upon
it a little bit elaborate I was thinking
about the subject after reading another
article about the so called decline of
Christianity in America and I don't
remember where the article is from but
it was it was pointing out how now today
70% of America is Christian and that
number is significantly lower than it's
ever been in history and that's where
the decline the so-called decline in
America is happening or so they tell us
but that's not really the problem there
is a problem there's a big problem in
American culture and with the church and
with Christianity Christianity is
declining in America that's for sure but
the problem is not with the 5 or 10 or
15 or 20% that we've lost over the
decades the problem is is within the 70%
that we still have we say that 70% of
America is Christian but there's
something seriously wrong
with our 70% because if 70% of us were
now that might be a smaller percentage
than at any other point in history but
70% is still a large percentage and if
70% of us were really authentically
substantially Christian well then we our
culture would be in pretty fine shape we
we we would see that reflected in the
culture wouldn't we when we look around
we would see that okay wow we are a a
still a Christian culture with 70% of us
Christian but we don't see that we're
not at Christian culture even though we
are a Christian population so it would
seem that a good portion of our 70% a
good portion of we Christians are not
really Christian in any meaningful sense
whatsoever here's the reality I think
the average American Christian is no
different not substantively different
from the average American atheist or
agnostic or secular person and this by
the way is true of most religions the
average American Jew I'm sure ben
shapiro would agree that the average
american jew is is secular is
essentially atheist in his in his belief
systems and in the way that he operates
America is a secular country and
secularism is like this disease and it's
infected all of us it's it's infected
every religion in America so then we
have to ask this question is it better
to be a secular Christian or a secular
secular person who is closer to
Redemption who who is easier to save is
it is it the atheist or the Christian
who functions as an atheist I think a
lot of us would tend to say well at
least the Christian believe
so he's in a better spot he doesn't have
a lot to worry about at least he
believes but I don't think that's the
case I think I think in fact if you had
to choose between being an atheist who
knows he's an atheist or an atheist who
thinks he's a Christian you're better
off being the atheist who knows he's an
atheist in my piece I Ellis trated the
point with two hypothetical people Bob
and Jim and I want to bring Bob and Jim
back into the conversation because I
think they're helpful framing device for
us so so first let's let's think about
Bob for a minute Bob Bob is not
Christian doesn't claim to be if he had
to pick a label he'd probably say he's
agnostic he might say he's spiritual but
not religious something like that but it
all kind of means the same thing and he
lives a normal life he he doesn't think
very much about these kinds of things
he's not contemplating eternity or or
the afterlife most of the time he
doesn't really think about it he doesn't
think about the fact that he's a mortal
person and he's going to die sooner
rather than later he doesn't think about
that he just does he does what normal
people do he he you know he watches porn
and he drinks a little too much on the
weekends and he watches a lot of TV
spends most of his time spends most of
his days just kind of staring into
various screens whether it's on his
phone or his computer or and that's how
he spends his time he his goal in life
is to be comfortable he wants pleasure
that's what he wants that's what he
craves the most and he works a job but
he works just to enrich himself whatever
money he has he spends on his himself or
he he saves he gives very little to
charity doesn't doesn't really worry
about that but he's nice to people and
and he won't sacrifice anything for them
but he's nice to them he's not gonna
sacrifice his comfort he's not going to
put himself out there for other people
most of the time but but he's nice to
them and he's nice to his wife most of
the time he likes his wife but he'll
leave her
if his feelings ever fade he'll leave
her and he likes his kids too but if his
home life ever becomes too boring or too
difficult or not fulfilling enough he'll
leave them also so he's a normal person
he's a nice person he's an empty person
and I think he represents a very large
portion of American society so then
there's Jim Jim calls himself a
Christian he doesn't think very much
about what that means
he believes vaguely kind of ambiguously
he believes that something like God
probably exists he accepts that Jesus
Christ died for his sins but he accepts
it passively he accepts it as a just a
fact he accepts it like he would accept
it if I told him the chemical
composition of the atmosphere of Jupiter
he would just say oh okay yeah that
that's what that's a thing so God and
Jesus and religion it's just the thing
and he's like yeah sure fine that yeah
that's that's that's true I guess he
doesn't he doesn't believe that the
details have any bearing on his life and
he thinks very little about all this
stuff
he doesn't like thinking about he
doesn't like talking about it he he he
in fact is even more hostile to
religious discussions than Bob he's the
kind of Christian you try to talk to him
about Christianity about the gospel he
gets very uncomfortable he doesn't want
to talk about it
he doesn't pray his inner life is
basically indistinguishable from Bob's
and his external life what he does how
he spends his time that is completely
indistinguishable if you were to if you
were to follow Jim around and observe
everything he does now this will be
weird and creepy to do but in this
hypothetical situation if you were to
follow Jim around observe everything he
does everything he says just how he
spends his time just everything that he
indulges in you would there be no
difference you
not see any substantial noticeable
difference at all between his life and
the life of Bob the atheist or the
agnostic or the spiritual but not
religious there is no different nothing
not even on them not even on Sundays
anymore he's not going to church either
he's just he's not doing anything he's
just living like everybody else lives
but he's a nice person and he's an empty
person and he does believe but there is
little to no evidence of that belief to
be found anywhere without him or within
him now I think that describes a lot of
Christians it's a depressing description
but it has to describe them because I
mean just just just look around you at
society look at the kind of media that
people watch look at the billion dollar
porn industry look at the state of
marriage in the family um clearly this
all can't be the fault if you look at
our culture and the way that it's
structured and set up it can't all be
the fault of the Bob's there aren't
enough Bob's walking or there aren't
enough atheists and secular people 70
percent of us are still Christians yet
we have created this society so there
must be a lot of gyms I mean a lot and
we know that because we've all met gyms
haven't we we've all met a lot of gyms
maybe we are gyms god forbid
so both Bob and Jim are in a in a
difficult
pateros situation Jim I think has it
worse and I'll tell you why because Jim
has the same emptiness and the same
indifference but he has something else
and it's a problem he has a sense of
security and it's a false sense of
security he believes that he's saved he
believes it because he he accepts God as
a fact and maybe he announced vocally at
some point that he's a Christian he said
I'm a Christian
it kind of reminds me of what that's
seen in the office right towards the end
of when the office stopped being funny I
think was season four the scene in the
office were Michael Scott goes bankrupt
and he's told the meet he needs to
declare bankruptcy so he walks out of
his office and just says I declare
bankruptcy in front of the office and he
had to be told no that's not how it
works just because you say it doesn't
mean anything and just because someone
says they're a Christian means nothing
those are just words
it's just it's just air coming out it's
just vocal chord vibrations and air and
then going out into the ether it doesn't
mean anything on its own it's just you
might as well announce that you're a
dolphin it doesn't mean anything
necessarily Bob on the other hand is
honest about who he is and what he
believes he knows that he's rejected God
and so we could pray that maybe he'll be
like the prodigal son he'll hit rock
bottom will find himself sleeping in the
mud with the pigs figuratively speaking
or maybe literally and then he'll look
around he'll say what's happening into
my life what's going on what am I
missing something is missing big is
missing from my life what is it and from
there we can hope that hopefully he
begins the ascent he begins the ascent
into hope but the problem for Jim we see
the problem for Jim is that he doesn't
feel God's absence in his life because
he's not honest about the fact that
there is in absence he's already
sleeping in the mud with the pigs but he
doesn't notice or he doesn't care see I
think it takes kind of a certain toll on
a man it causes real damage to stand in
the light of God to look at God to
accept that he is real and yet still to
turn from him and reject him there's
there are a lot of defense mechanisms
that you have to use a lot of walls you
have to
in order to make that work the the
Christian who lives like an atheist has
to contort himself twist himself into
pretzels and it's gonna be harder and
harder to untwist himself and he's less
likely to even try because he believes
but he doesn't really believe I'll tell
you what he really does he acknowledges
Jim acknowledges Christ he acknowledges
the cross he kind of nods towards it and
says yeah sure he acknowledges but
that's not belief anyone who thinks they
can get to heaven because they've
acknowledged a reality is severely
misled that's not believed that's not a
Christian belief is and so we begin to
understand that there's there has to be
a difference between saying I believe
that such and such as true and saying I
believe in there's a big difference and
I think a lot of us are that Christians
we believe that God is real Christ is
real Christ died we believe that we
believe it as a fact we believe it as a
reality we believe it like we believe
that dogs are mammals and sharks live in
the ocean but but so fine we believe
that but we don't believe in the analogy
that I used is is is imagine you know
you see a bridge over a over a prayer
over a very deep canyon and you could
say yeah I believe that bridge exists
you can acknowledge the existence of the
bridge that's the believing that of the
bridge but if you believe in the bridge
then you'll walk across it and if you
won't walk across the bridge it means
you don't believe in it you don't trust
it you don't have faith in it you won't
depend on it you're not going to trust
it with your life I think a lot of us as
Christians we are standing a good
distance from the bridge and just
pointing to the bridge and saying
there's a bridge and we think that's
enough we think that there's no walking
involved there's no depending no
trusting nothing it's just pointing and
saying there it is but believing in in
Jesus is is submitting to him following
him loving him I really think we could
alleviate a lot of the confusion if
rather than saying well a Christian has
to believe in Jesus that's true
but then also I think it may be more
accurate and more helpful to say a
Christian has to love Jesus you have to
love him and loving goes far beyond a
mere acknowledgment of a fact I could
acknowledge that my wife exists that's
good I mean that's a first step I guess
but that if I treat her like she doesn't
exist
what could is it will my marriage
survive does my marriage even exist if
that's the way that I operate
so that's what it is I think you know we
believe that we haven't graduated to the
in and for that reason I think in the
end we end up being even worse than
those who don't have that or in far
worse because it's one thing to deny
that Christ is real it's another thing
to accept that he's real and then refuse
to submit to him because that is pride I
mean that's the worst thing of all that
is a willful conscience conscious
rejection it's literally what Satan did
and we know that Satan is not an atheist
that's the problem we always run into
with the Christians who think that all
we got to do is just believe a fact just
acknowledge it how do you explain Satan
why is it say I mean it seems if that's
the case and a great injustice was done
to Satan because Satan knows he does
more than believe he knows he know he
believes more than any of us he knows
for a fact and yet he's still in hell
and why is that because he refused to
submit he had he knew the fact he knew
the reality accepted that but he didn't
love God he refused to love he refused
to believe in him he refused to be in in
God and so I think it's if we're if
we're look at Bob and Jim I think it's I
think we would have to admit that Satan
is much closer to Jim than he is to Bob
and so unfortunately Jim is much closer
to him
and I think I know that's an
uncomfortable fact to face but it's one
that I think we need to face and think
about and consider whether we are
whether we are the gems of modern
culture
alright guys thanks for watching have a
great day and I'll talk to you tomorrow